the way I would put it is that Obamacare
is sort of standing on the edge of a
death spiral kind of looking down into
it it may not be in a death spiral as of
yet hi I'm Nicolas me with Reason TV
today we're talking with Peter Souter
Bernie's features editor at reason and
he writes a lot about Obamacare and
healthcare in general big news recently
is that the middle tier of coverage
options in Obamacare on the Obamacare
exchanges are the premiums for those are
going up by about 25 percent but you've
written that prices to most consumers
won't increase what's going on yes so
the this is an interesting situation
with Obamacare about three-quarters of
the people who get their coverage
through the exchanges are not gonna see
a huge price increase in what they pay
even though premiums are going up by
about 25 percent for an average middle
tier plan and the reason is that the way
the subsidies are designed under the law
is that they are pegged to go up
according to the price of what's called
the benchmark plan which is the second
lowest cost plan and the silver tier
it's all a little bit complicated but
basically when premiums go up subsidies
go up along with that and so subsidies
cover people up to about 400% of the
poverty line that's and that is about
for a family for making up to about
ninety seven thousand dollars okay so so
the subsidies are going up then who's
picking up the premium Inc so what
happens when the subsidies increase is
that the cost to the government which is
to say to those of us who are taxpayers
goes up as well however the cost is
going to go up for some individuals
those people who are above the who don't
qualify for subsidies people who make
more than 400% of the poverty line as
their annual income and so you that's a
little less than a quarter of the people
who get their plans through Obamacare
and those people are gonna feel the full
brunt of the increases and so that leads
you to worrisome to some extent that
those people might choose to go
about insurance so for about a quarter
of the people they'll be paying the full
cost of the increase in their Obamacare
premium that's right they're paying the
full cost of their plan already they're
getting no subsidies right and so when
the plan price goes up they will pay the
full cost of the increase as well and so
that's gonna change the calculation and
so that means if it's a 25% increase on
a $400 a month premium it would go up to
$500 that's right although it's
important to understand that these are
average yeses yeah and so in some places
the increases are gonna be somewhat
smaller but in some places we've seen
increases in the 30 40 even 60% range
and so it's really gonna vary by region
in particular rural regions are gonna
see the biggest increases and then in
2019 the subsidy caps go away so that
means that the the government will be
subsidizing less of the increases
explaining how that works right now the
situation is that if you are subsidized
most of the increase in your premiums
will be covered by the subsidy but
starting in a few years people even
people who get subsidies are going to
start to feel the pain of increases
because the way the subsidy is
calculated is gonna change and so what's
gonna happen is that this insulation
that people have this kind of buffer
from premium increases exists for right
now but is going to go away in a few
years and that is going to make it even
more likely that those people are might
choose to pay a penalty rather than to
purchase insurance and and I mean those
the premiums are going up because the
health insurance companies miscalculated
how much on average it was going to cost
to cover people the premiums are going
up because the insurance pool turned out
to be somewhat sicker than expected and
therefore more expensive and also it
turned out to be smaller than expected
so if you look at the initial
projections from the Congressional
Budget Office they said
enrollments as of last year was going to
be about 40 percent higher in the
exchanges than it turned out to be so
it's a smaller sicker pool which means
that it costs more ultimately I mean
there's less cost-sharing and there's
more sickness so the price - who has
ever left goes up is this you know
people talk a lot about death spirals in
Obamacare is this a death spiral or is
this kind of a loping wounded you know
one wing dove or something what what
what what what comes next so that is the
big question the administration's
position is that this is a one time
correction they've called this a
transition year for the law and they are
arguing or maybe better they're hoping
that insurance premiums kind of
stabilize and that enrollment stabilizes
at this point and I think that remains
to be seen if you look at what's going
on with the premiums about it like I
said a little less than a quarter of
people are going to be affected by them
and those people are gonna have some
incentive are at least going to have a
reason to think about maybe dropping out
this year maybe going without coverage
there are some projections projections
that are already indicating that
enrollment is likely to be flat this
year and it's gonna be difficult for
Obamacare to keep going with stagnating
enrollments especially if they can't
sort of replace some of the sicker
people with somewhat healthier people
it's an open question I think at this
point by the way I would put it is that
Obamacare is sort of standing on the
edge of a death spiral kind of looking
down into it it may not be in a death
spiral as of yet now President Obama has
been talking and taking credit for a
slowdown in the rate of increase in
medical costs he says look you know we
passed Obamacare in 2010 and the rate of
increase is is lower than it had been is
it that clear that Obamacare has
anything to do with the direction of
medical
cause I know it is not there is some
correlation it's very difficult to prove
causation because medical inflation
depending on which measure you use was
actually dropping starting years before
Obamacare was passed so does Obamacare
get credit for everything that happened
after Obamacare was passed maybe some
credit maybe a lot maybe a little it's
actually hard to say and it's hard to
really pin down causality here the sort
of the political point on this though
that that's worth thinking about is
Obama is making the argument that most
people who have insurance through their
jobs that is not through Obamacare are
saving about $3,600 a year relative to
what they would be paying without
Obamacare in place and what he's really
doing is making a kind of a
counterfactual argument it's here you're
you've got savings relative to this
alternate history and not it's it's not
actually savings you're paying more
you're just paying less more than you
might have been in some history that
didn't in some other timeline and he's
saying that's all because of Obamacare
even though the trajectory in inflation
was not going to zero or below zero but
it was slowing down before Obamacare was
passed he's giving Obamacare significant
credit for this
this is presidential election year
obviously how is health care and Obama
care playing out in terms of the
election of 2016 well you basically got
two arguments one from Hillary Clinton
which is that yes this law has some
problems but let's not scrap it and I
will fix it she tends not to dwell too
much on her particular fixes but the one
thing that she has spoken about probably
most prominently is that she supports
what's known as a public option that's a
government-run health insurance plan
that would compete compete alongside of
private insurers in at least some of the
exchanges maybe in all of them she
hasn't provided a huge number of details
in terms of how she
do this she's also suggested that she
might allow people who are younger than
65 to buy into Medicare thus opening up
some additional options for them Donald
Trump on the other hand has basically
toed the Republican line on we need to
repeal Obamacare and replace it with
something else
it's not at all clear that he
understands how Obamacare works what it
is or has any real plan to replace it
he's harped on this idea of getting rid
of the lines around the states which if
you're being charitable is a reference
to letting people buy insurance across
state lines but it's not clear that he
understands why you would want to do
that because his plan would keep the
regulations within States in place and
she's also been totally unable to
explain it he seems to think that
Obamacare some may have something to do
with a workplace insurance it doesn't at
all I mean it's what's really what you
know or our voters you know where they
do they do people like Obamacare more
than they used to less than they'd like
to or they I you know just shrugging and
not being able to figure anything out a
little bit of the latter the trend lines
for Obamacare and the polls have been
pretty consistent over the years which
is to say that it is somewhat less there
is somewhat more unpopular than it is
popular more people dislike it then like
it the gap is typically anywhere from 3
to 7 points and so Obamacare just sort
of continues to chug along with many
Democrats liking it many Republicans
opposing it and more people overall
opposing the law than favoring it well
we will leave it there we've been
talking with Peter Sudirman he is the
features editor at Reason check out his
work about Obamacare and other issues at
reason.com
for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie